c'est sur son compte instagram qu'alexei
navali a annoncé sa volonté d'entamer
une grève de la faim afin de dénoncer
les mauvais traitements dont ils
estiment être victimes
d'après ce qu'on peut lire sur cette
publication sur les réseaux sociaux
le personnel de la prison dans laquelle
il est incarcéré le priverait de sommeil
et l'empêcherait d'avoir accès à un
médecin ainsi qu'à des médicaments alors
qu'il souffre actuellement du dos le
porte parole de vladimir poutine
interrogé sur la question a répondu que
ce sujet n'était pas du ressort du
kremlin
vous savez il ya des organisations de
défense des droits de l'homme des
organisations sociales qui s'occupe de
la surveillance de la situation dans les
établissements du service fédéral
d'exécution des peines elle fournit des
questions des propositions et en
coopération avec les autorités
elle s'occupe de l'examen des
propositions formulées les cas
particuliers sont à examiner par le
service fédéral d'exécution des peines
et les agences spécialisées
ils ne font aucune manière l'objet de
nos commentaires pour rappel alexeï
navalni a été interpellé dès son retour
en russie en janvier dernier puis
condamné à purger une peine de deux ans
et huit mois de prison ferme dans une
affaire de détournement de fonds dans
laquelle il avait dans un premier temps
été condamné à du sursis opposants
russes revenaient alors de sa
convalescence en allemagne où il avait
été soigné après une tentative supposée
d'empoisonnement